[Musique]
la désinformation ne fait pas que
fausser la réalité et 10 torsionnelle
effet c'est aussi une opportunité
d'affaires une source de revenus voire
une industrie la journaliste et youtube
buzz française aude favre alias aude
what the fuck s'est donné pour mission
d'explorer ce qu'elle a baptisé la
business des fêtes news au coeur de
cette très lucrative filière la
publicité des espaces publicitaires
achetés par des entreprises sur des
sites web qui génère de la
désinformation un cercle vicieux
alimenté par des compagnies souvent
multinationales sans qu'elle ne le sache
nécessairement
mais d'abord c'est un plaisir de te
recevoir chez nous décrypte heures au
bon soir salut
bonsoir alors pour cette première
conversation on va parler de la belle
nice des fausses nouvelles de la
désinformation tutti intéressé dans le
cas de ton reportage de ton documentaire
plutôt fait news la machine à fric
diffusé sur les chaînes france 2 et
france info alors parlons de la business
de la désinfo mais en chiffres ça
rapporte combien
est bien le business de la
désinformation c'est quelque chose qui
est absolument colossal et qui n'est
pourtant pas connu fin regardez autour
de vous demander est ce que tu es au
courant de combien ça chiffre le
business de la désinformation personne
n'est au courant seront les mêmes les
gens ne savent pas qu'il y à un business
de la désinformation et pourtant on
parle de plus de 3 milliards de dollars
canadiens je précise une chose c'est
qu'il s'agit de trois milliards de
dollars canadien néo minimum et
simplement il s'agit de revenus
publicitaires simplement c'est à dire
que les producteurs de désinformation
aussi des goodies ils font des
formations des conférences il en est où
toutes sortes de revenus possibles et
imaginables là on parle simplement des
revenus publicitaires plus de 3
milliards de dollars canadiens vous êtes
donc intéressé aux coulisses de la
business de la désinformation aux
coulisses de cet univers comment ça
fonctionne quelle architecture de la
business de la désinformation
en fait c'est très simple ça s'appelle
la publicité programmatique la publicité
programmatique vous permet grâce au web
de cibler des personnes c'est-à-dire
vous voulez cibler les jeunes filles de
25 ans qui habite dans le sud de
montréal et qui font du cheval et qui
chose due 37 eh bien vous pourrez le
faire grâce à la publicité et donc les
marques ciblent maintenant des profils
de gens si ces gens là se retrouvent à
se consulter des sites
conspirationnistes décide et ne décide
vraiment dangereux du grand n'importe
quoi et bien les marques quelque part
vont les suivre en fait vont les
chercher à la trace et c'est ça qui mène
à ces trois milliards de dollars dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et là on parle de
ses marques de façon très générique avez
vous des exemples à nous donner pauvres
à comprendre l'ampleur du phénomène à
écouter en fait que ce que j'ai fait moi
je suis en train de bâtir une réaction
citoyenne anti fait que news on va dire
anti des informations et donc on et 1500
mais ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
pris cinquante citoyens français en
l'occurrence pour les besoins du
documentaire
et pendant deux mois ils ont leur
mission était de prendre des captures
d'écran de toutes les marques qui
s'affichait sur une vingtaine de sites d
information et on a on a vu que paypal
par exemple était sur le podium des
marques qui s'affiche sur ce genre sur
ce genre de
deux sites on a vu aussi calvin klein
beaucoup amazon sur braye bart par
exemple qui est quand même un site qui
dit que le réchauffement climatique est
un mythe qui est vraiment ni le
consensus scientifique sur un certain
nombre de choses on a retrouvé sans son
gossip beaucoup sur un site qui
s'appelle le gateway bendit pour qui par
exemple les masques cause des morts
prématurées
qui disent que joe biden appel au djihad
par exemple on a retrouvé ce genre de
choses voyez donc cent en dessous était
par exemple là dessus et puis ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a des enquêteurs
dans la rédaction qui sont québécois qui
s'appelle camoël c'est fructis c'est
leur petit pseudo et je leur ai demandé
du coup de faire une recherche la très
récemment et par exemple ils ont trouvé
des publicités pour l'université
d'ottawa sur un site qui dit que bill
gates veut implanter des micropuces etc
qui s'appelle anguille sous roche l'abbé
best buy walmart sur d'autres sites
hyper problématique un haut niveau
informationnel ses bons coups hier comme
ricky strike ou anguille sous roche
encore et quand vous avez tendu la
perche assez grande entreprise qu'est ce
qu'ils avaient à répondre à ce sujet là
on a contacté je dirais 60 presque 70
marques qui se retrouvaient vraiment
beaucoup sur ce genre de sites la
plupart ne nous ont même pas répondu
chacun aime à le dire et puis certaines
en fait enfin toutes celles qui nous
répondait nous faisait qu elle faisait
déjà le maximum pour éviter ce genre de
site donc ça ça pose quand même beaucoup
question en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que
les marques peuvent très bien si
vraiment elle le souhaite ne pas
s'afficher sur sur sur ces sites là mais
déjà piana pas mal qui n'ont pas qu'ils
sont pas assez sensibilisés je pense aux
problèmes qui ont pas trop conscience de
ça ou qui sont fiche
et puis et puis personne quelque part ne
lance l'alertent là dessus ça leur coûte
très peu en fait en image de marque
aujourd'hui une main peu qui s'affiche
sur un site super problématique il ya
pas grand monde qui va venir l'embêter
là dessus donc et s'ajoute à cela le
fait que
même si celle le disent pas beaucoup de
sites conspirationnistes
attire beaucoup beaucoup de gens et donc
faut beaucoup de clics et donc ont
beaucoup de trafic et ça peut être aussi
intéressant en fait pour pour beaucoup
de marques d'être sur ce genre de sites
et puis la part de cet argent là qui va
sur des problématiques
et reste reste pas grande en fait c'est
à dire que beaucoup de marques nous ont
dit oui vous savez ça représente très
peu finalement de nos achats
publicitaires sur le web etc c'est pas
grand chose sauf que
pas grand chose de rôles mart plus pas
grand-chose de best buy plus pas
grand-chose de nike + pas grand-chose de
toutes les marques qu'on a vu ça aboutit
à des sommes absolument colossal souvent
les gens il ya des gens qui m'ont dit
c'est paralysant ce que tu dis on sait
pas quoi faire le truc est tellement
colossal etc je tiens juste à mentionner
qu'il ya une organisation qui s'appelle
sleeping terrienne qui oeuvre contre ça
et que je demande aux gens de suivre sur
twitter parce que ils font que ça
interpellés les marques sur le fait
qu'elles sont elles s'affichent sur sur
des sites problématiques et aussi voilà
je voudrais que les gens qui ont des
entreprises les gens qui gèrent des
entreprises essayez de faire attention
regardez où est ce que vous mettez vos
voalavo encarts publicitaires il ya des
il ya des entreprises comme news garde
ou comme stories i dont je parle dans le
documentaire qui peuvent vous aider
justement avoir des campagnes
publicitaires entre guillemets un peu
propres quoi voilà
la pandémie a été synonyme de gros
profits aux biens des propagateurs de
désinformation notamment grâce à la
publicité programmatique alors comment
faire pour empêcher que les entreprises
16 de financer involontairement à
travers leurs publicités les sites web
qui disséminent des informations fausses
ou trompeuses et n'oscille l'entreprise
young girl s'est donné pour mission d'
assez dire cet écosystème jeune abbé
bonsoir
vous êtes la rédactrice en chef de la
branche européenne de news corp dont
c'était déjà parlé l'an dernier
bienvenue aux décrypteurs mafia vous new
skies a récemment publié une étude sur
la publicité programmatique en temps de
pandémie ce qui nous a beaucoup frappé
c'est de voir à quel point des
entreprises qui luttent contre la coved
19 se sont retrouvés à financer des
sites web qui font de la désinformation
basé sur la pandémie de kobe 19
oui effectivement on a fait un rapport
montrant que plus de 4000 marques
connues réputé avaient placé leurs
publicités sur des filles sur des sites
diffusant de fausses informations sur le
co vide on parle de sites diffusant des
enfants du type la pandémie a été
planifié par bill gates les vaccins
contre le colis de 19 on vous
transformer en chimpanzé décide vraiment
en diffusant de fausses d'information
dangereuse pour la santé publique et
parmi ces marques effectivement c'est
assez frappant de voir des systèmes
hospitaliers américains pfizer qui
évidemment n'a aucun intérêt à se
retrouver sur des sites diffusant des
enfants que sur son propre vaccin est
donc en fait ce dont on se rend compte
c'est que ce qui se passe là c'est
totalement involontaire de la part des
marques et c'est dû à un système la
publicité programmatique qui est très
complexe qui est automatisée qui repose
sur l'intelligence artificielle en fait
c'est la mise en relation automatique de
d'acheteurs et de vendeurs d'espacé
publicitaire en ligne et le fait que ce
système soit si compliqué fait que les
publicités échappe
aux marques qui en sont à l'origine et
alors qu'est ce que news google propose
pour lutter contre ce phénomène
planétaire chez milgram on analyse la
fiabilité des fuites d'informations en
fonction de critères journalistiques de
base de crédibilité de transparence et
donc on va aider les marques à
ajouter des sites à leur liste
d'exclusion c'est à dire les listes où
elles vont sur les sites où elles vont
surtout pas à les diffuser leurs leurs
publicités et puis on va aussi les aider
et ça c'est l'aspect le plus
enthousiasmant de mon travail finalement
les aider à rediriger cet argent vers
des sites d'actualité
responsables des sites qui font d'eux
voilà qui font du journalisme
comme si vous le faites chez radio
canada et comme beaucoup de journalistes
responsables le fond et c'est moi est ce
que les internautes eux mêmes peuvent
contribuer à cette prise de conscience
des grandes entreprises je pense que la
prise de conscience elle a déjà lieu on
l'a on la voit déjà les marques se
rendent compte et et prennent possession
de ce sujet pourquoi parce que depuis un
mois les enjeux ont changé d'échelle on
parle de désinformation sur le colis de
19 sur les vaccins sur
sur la protection de la population dont
on parle de problème de santé publique
on parle aussi de fausses informations
sur l'intégrité électorale donc les
enjeux sont de taille
je pense que les marques et les agences
s'en rendent compte et se saisisse du
sujet il faut que ça ce que ça continue
c'est une bonne chose et donc peut-être
qu'effectivement les citoyens peuvent
aider à ce que cette prise de conscience
garde un certain momentum et ne retombe
pas